coinbase wallet which is a
self-custodial wallet
is more decentralized and it allows
people to
um hold their own crypto they don't have
to trust us can you explain what a
self-custodial wallet is what is the
wallet and what is the self-custodial
wallet yeah so it's confusing so um so a
custodial wallet means you're trusting
coinbase to store your crypto the
private Keys themselves and you know for
some people in institutions and
everything just meeting them where they
are today that's nice because it's
simpler you know
um they're not afraid of losing their
crypto if they make some accident
accidental mistake or so you know a
custodial
um crypto products are important to help
get a bunch of people into the ecosystem
but
I'm very supportive of self-custodial
wallets and I think in some ways they
are the future because more and more
people are going to want to store their
own crypto not trust a third-party
institution do it and in some ways that
is much more authentic to the ethos of
crypto so coinbase will help you convert
the Fiat into crypto in a frankly that's
a more centralized thing but once you
have crypto you can then go to the
self-custodial world store it yourself
in in a to get into the technical
details just for a second it's basically
saying um you're going to store the keys
on your own device and so um even if
coinbase you know gets some court order
to seize it we actually can't like from
an architecture point of view we can't
do it
um or you know if coinbase gets hacked
or something we can't lose your funds
like now you the thing is you have to
take the responsibility because we're
not taking it so the individual person
could get hacked right and there's a
whole bunch of really cool research
happening to make self-custodial wallets
more resilient to Accidental loss hacks
and just user error like you know
um there's I don't know how much you've
looked at like various cryptography
things but there's like basically um you
can have multiple key multi-sig multiple
signatures from different keys on
different devices where you need like
two of the three or three of the five
there's a whole um technology called a
multi-party computation or threshold
signing signatures which is really cool
but those are the things you would run
locally
like what these are all security
measures like cryptography measures to
protect you without a centralized
component right so like a simple example
would be let's say you had a two of
three key signature and you know one key
might be stored at coinbase but that's
not a quorum so we couldn't unilaterally
move your funds but another key is on
your device on your phone let's say oh
cool um so that so in a normal situation
you have a key on your phone we have one
um but you and so two out of three now
just you know it can all get signed very
quickly for day-to-day use but let's say
you lose your phone or something now
there has to be a third key and that's
where you know you could store it in a
backup somewhere
um like in Google Drive or iCloud you
could trust a third party that's not
coinbase to also have that one key and
but they can't do anything unilaterally
with that one key so that's a simple
example you can get you can get way more
complicated yeah that's an awesome idea
and so like yeah if your funds get
seized coinbase can't can't do anything
right uh but you better not lose your
phone maybe in that case yeah yeah but
it provides a there is so even if you
lose your phone then there is a recovery
mechanism because you can get the one
key from coinbase the one from your
backup provider and recover a new one
back on your phone I know yeah but but
what if coinbase is no longer but
because of government because of a say
it's in North Korea Government says
you're no longer like coinbase is shut
down in that country or something like
that right then you can get it even if
you have access to those two right so uh
again
perhaps a silly question but isn't a
self-custodial wallet a competitor as a
notion to coinbase
no I mean we so we offer a
self-custodial wallet
um we've built one and it's like but
doesn't it bleed the like I guess I'm
asking a sort of a financial question is
uh like how does coinbase make money on
transactions so does this not does it
does not decrease the number or does not
significantly negatively affect
transactions or are you more focused on
growing the number of the pie of the
number of people that are using
cryptocurrency yeah like a traditional
Financial Service firm would probably
say well we should be storing let's keep
more of the custody with us because
that's how we prove to the world that
we're valuable or whatever
I don't really believe that like I think
that actually we kind of want to
encourage our users to move to
self-custody over time for those who are
ready and willing and that technology
needs to mature I'm not trying to like
force anybody to do it who doesn't want
to do it but
to me that's like the future of how we
get billions of people using crypto but
doesn't that mean they can go somewhere
else
easier yeah that's sort of the point is
like we're all using the same protocol
so there's low switching costs which
keeps all the companies accountable
right like
if you if you want to access the Visa
Network there's only one company in the
world you can go through to do that like
Visa but if you want to access the
Bitcoin Network there's dozens or
hundreds of companies out there who can
do that so it's you know it's arguably
You could argue it's worse for us as a
company but I think it's better for it's
what makes Bitcoin interesting and
cryptocurrency interesting is that
nobody controls it there is low
switching cost for customers it's better
for customers and that means that all
the companies in the space are going to
be held to a high standard because the
minute you lose someone's trust they're
just going to move their Bitcoin to some
other service
and that's good for the world